Martha's vineyard's an idyllic spot in
the Atlantic Ocean of Massachusetts but
for decades now people in Martha's
Vineyard have been pining for diversity
we need more diversity we need more
diversity well diversity finally arrives
sent on a Jet Plane by Ron DeSantis and
the second diversity arrived the locals
the ones who pined for diversity called
the Army and had diversity shipped to a
military base where apparently diversity
belongs
ooh
people were not too upset at Martha's
Vineyard as diversity was led away to a
military base watch
[Applause]
those are Cheers uh in Martha's Vineyard
this morning just before migrants
boarded buses to go on to Joint Base
Cape Cod
the brown people are leaving we're so
excited go brown people go don't come
home
if you're not my housekeeper get off the
island
so it may seem like they're bigots I
mean what's the other conclusion but no
according to CNN they're just grateful
they were clapping in gratitude for Ron
DeSantis and what he did the gift that
he gave them here's an actual scene in
headlight we didn't believe this was
real but it is and we're quoting they
enriched us migrants 44-hour visit
leaves indelible mark on Martha's
Vineyard
44 hours
wow that didn't take long to leave an
indelible mark less than two days in the
same zip code with Venezuelans and their
lives are changed forever
this reminds you of the kid in your
class who adopted a Spanish accent after
spring break in Cabo
the guy who converted to Islam because
he once switched planes in Dubai it
seems a little premature right
so we decided to look into it is
Martha's Vineyard really congratulating
itself for surviving its ever so brief
encounter with Hispanics yes it is
one non-profit on the island called the
Martha's Vineyard Community Foundation
posted this message on his website again
this is real our immigrant visitors have
left the island they have expressed
enormous gratitude for the outpouring of
support and generosity showed by the
Allen Community which was heartfelt and
overflowing
oh man
to a military base
but the Hispanics are very grateful to
be shipped by to a military base by the
Army they're grateful for the attention
the foundation also praised Island
residents for raising forty thousand
dollars in a fundraiser for the migrants
oh but not really for the migrants
because none of the money is going to
actual migrants of course it's not quote
The Vineyard Community stepped up in an
unprecedented way really on whose behalf
owe its own
the money went to them they raised money
for themselves not for the Venezuelans
hilarious
but if you want to know in any Community
across the United States where the
Locust of self-congratulatory posturing
is we're the most insufferable people in
any given town that of course would be
the local Episcopal Church in eggert's
town or Martha's Vineyard that is Saint
Andrews Episcopal and needless to say as
their inclination they
self-congratulated big time quote
we have been so overwhelmed with
everyone's kind words and thought and
financial support for our brothers and
sisters from Venezuela
and deported instantly by men with guns
so we thought we'd check in with our
brothers and sisters in Venezuela but
unfortunately they're locked up on a
military base so they could not be
reached for comment tonight subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight